[Music]
in balan boy news y submitted by barbell
brigade - Oh where's that at I guess
they're trying to say you gotta open up
another all right where would your next
location be China
it's [ __ ] popping off in China but
barbells committed entire different
universe over there the 15 year old son
of a Dubai business tycoon is capturing
attention with his insanely rich
lifestyle oh we see the one that vlogs I
think I've seen his vlogs it's [ __ ]
bonkers really there's a bunch of guys
that walk in there a bunch there's a
bunch of because the guy that Adam
showed us I think he's over 18 yeah I
think I know who you're talking about
and I think that guy did a thing with
this guy he's a kid he has like a
$40,000 watching something it's like
nothing to him what the hell
probably yeah there's might be a lot of
them yeah yeah yeah yeah depend on what
charity yeah so this kid he's 15 his
name is Rashid bel Haase and he's the
youngest son I like I should just bow
when I hear that name ready I'm so royal
yeah okay Rashid Baha I am presenting
the Prince the Lord of the Seven sands
the man of our man's the child of all
child the man of almonds the stand of
Austin's the kids of all came the kids
of our kids the tamer of lions yeah he
actually hasn't zoo oh really
whoa yeah so this kid the owner of
Lamborghinis the father of peach fuzz
[Laughter]
Rasheed I saw all right so his dad is a
business tycoon famous naive amid
once again oh wait how do you become a
tycoon because like that's very
different like when I hear tycoon I
think like emperor of business well
pretty much so him he's the founding
chairman of Balasa International which
net worth is about 2 point 1 billion
okay so in the About section of that
website of the Bell Haase international
it says that they have business
interests such as real estate
construction automotive technology
education trading insurance investment
travel and tourism so just to own the
world basically conglomerate this kid he
hangs out with celebrities he has gained
thousands of followers on social media
he has seven hundred eighty eight
thousand on YouTube and six hundred and
seventy eight thousand on Instagram I
hang out with celebrities too I know
Bobby Lee o Davis all justin chon he was
in a movie mmm-hmm Rufio Dante Basco I
know people yeah so he lives in this
really lavish mansion that's surrounded
by private zoo features rare exotic
animals like lions tigers chimpanzees
cheetahs and Panthers ice live around a
zoo
I have one wild dog Maddy Sophie a
scared dog
I have stray cats I have crackheads
around my neighborhood I'm surrounded by
a zoo called Skid Row you're on the same
level is good yep
yeah so he they're saying I was in this
article they were like it will be a lot
faster to name out all the a-list
celebrities that have not visited this
kid that's how many celebrities visit
this kid Wow why did they visit him yeah
the other private Zoo and so he's saying
that he get so many like inquiries to
come probably [ __ ] sponsors them maybe
yeah like he's like what are you that oh
my god I just want to I need to meet
like Nick Cannon right now and then like
his dad's like okay send the Nick Cannon
over fifty thousand dollars I bet you
cuz if I was a rich dad and my son was
like dad a like I really wanted me like
Mickey Mouse I'll be like okay
Disney bring Mickey Mouse no are you
saying that that there would be
celebrities I want to come over and
visit but they he even have to say no to
them because either he doesn't have time
where it's just too tiring to entertain
me celebrity Rihanna I told you my
schedules BC he's like 50 you don't
wanna play Minecraft with you it's wait
where did that statement come from is
actually that statements bogus like I
don't believe that well I mean he's like
with Khalifa's my friend Steve Aoki's my
friend Steve Harvey went to go visit him
Messi went to go visit him like he you
guys Instagram account it's nothing but
like celebrity photos or like him with
celebrities and then they're checking
out his insane shoe collection he has
because his YouTube channel it's like
all about his shoes he's trying to be a
businessman as well like his dad
so he's been investing in a lot of
really rare sneakers and he sees it as a
business opportunity because he's like
you know yeah I might be spending a
whole bunch of money on shoes right now
but they're gonna triple in their value
later and so he's like my dad understand
that he's like one time I went to France
and I bought more than 20 shoes my dad
thought I was crazy but he knows that
this is an investment in two years or
price will triple what got him he's
trying to be a business and I like
but yeah I mean he has an agent that
handled these celebrity meet-and-greet
like I believe the kid so here I'm gonna
show you guys some photos here he is
with the custom supreme and believe it's
easy on the sand yeah he's with this
other youtuber he has 3.8 million
subscribers it's no vlogs and he's also
in device and his life looks like I
don't really know his background a lot
but this is the kid he has a tiger I
hope I'm not allergic to that guy Tigers
nah rich kids I'm skinny
yeah and even like yes Steve Harvey want
to go visit him yeah that's so crazy
yeah Fat Joe Fat Joe this guy I see him
in all the oh yeah he's that guy yeah he
just lives a very lavish life
everything's all supreme
I feel so bad for him yeah don't turn to
a douche kid yeah well I was thinking
and in the comments they're like oh this
kid looks like he's really humbled for
the amount of well thing he has you just
look humble like his face like his
demeanor just from the photos I had a
lot of other kids I'm I try to ask yeah
they like act hard he's just like
smiling like what the regular team where
are the pictures of his friends that's
why I feel bad all of his friends are
celebrities why isn't his friends why
isn't he buying like ice cream or
something in like with his buddies like
cuz he's already passed that stage
that's why I feel bad all the ice cream
shop if I own the ice cream shop just
feel bad he's not going through all the
trials and tribulations that a regular
kid goes through I know kids that
elevate real early in life and they wish
they could connect with people and they
finally do and they're all adults and
they're happy is that a shoe office yeah
oh yeah this is his shoe room so it is
YouTube is money kicks and I'm gonna
show you guys one minute videos insane
that looks like the room from Kingsman
except with instead of guns its shoes
yeah here we go
that's a pretty dope rules be honest a
[Music]
[ __ ] friend made the beat I'm gonna
rock my Ferrari this is my new car so
they'll be supreme collaboration oh my
god
yeah that's crazy this is the best car
in Devoy the best car in the world
okay I'm just so blessed to have this
car shot at two for the extra text I'm
just so blessed you can't even drive if
you can just to give you guys some
perspective at the lv supreme collab
it's so expensive i was curious and they
have a small little backpack in at
$7,000 oh my god so that wrap if it's
official I don't know how it might even
be a hundred grand or so different to
get on top of them see this is what I
mean by stupid rich like this is just
stupid this is like present-day royalty
like that's some King Louie [ __ ] people
think kings and queens don't exist
anymore they do they're on Dubai they do
they're called children of business
owners yeah hi Kunz tycoons I think I
would be different I probably have is
another shoe room I have like a mini
Krispy Kremes in my house and every
morning just spits out donuts and then I
would have a Krispy Kreme wrap Ferrari
oh yeah Krispy Kreme and Brazilian
barbecue it would just be Brazilian
barbecue wrapped around a Hummer
Wow how many crispy cruisers you eat
realistically if you had a Krispy Kreme
probably at least twelve in the morning
and then I could eat a whole box I could
you inhale them yeah they ones nothing
he's gonna be the mayor of Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs oh yeah you just
lonely getting like turning I know I'd
be so fat if I was really really rich oh
man you know what I would do I would
have a palace and the whole bottom floor
is eight buffets eight eight different
different cuisines I mean like eight
buffet restaurants like but then like
one would be like Asian themed yeah so
it'll be like different parts of the
world yeah that's a waste of a food
no no but here listen to it this is to
my muscle story the game's gonna be in
slipping ramen I'm not only not only my
friends but all the hungry people of the
world because I want company I get
lonely
yeah they get to eat for free no but
you're also sensitive to smell how you
can do that oh yeah well they're not
gonna be stinky people you're gonna get
mean they're not homeless they're just
hungry
no crackheads allowed okay I'm thinking
about like oh there's a refugee family
crackheads got crack they could survive
off crack they're hungry for crack
hungry they can eat french fries and
fight between a pigeon [ __ ] I don't care
but I was thinking okay let's teleport
like all the decent people that are just
struggling and they're doing all that
they can but they just don't have who
okay the people that deserve it not the
[ __ ] crackheads they're [ __ ] lazy
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Applause]
[Music]